a lot of girls who are promiscuous  because when I went to school there was  like there were girls who did that but  you could like identify it was like this  one over here this one over here they  had a reputation and a bad one and all  the guys like knew who they were could  we could we Define promiscuous because  that sleeps around okay what is so then  we go into like what is sleep surround I  would say 90 by 1950 standards 90 of  women are promiscuous they're like you  slept with more than two people you  [ __ ] so what I mean is sex that that's  not within the context of an actual  relationship multiple sex partners at  once then in terms of like you're dating  multiple guys you're sleeping with them  it's not an exclusive relationship  that's what I Define as promiscuous yeah